a huge explosion lights up kiev
the fighting reaching the skies above
the ukrainian capital
on the ground residential buildings have
been hit
in the east of the country ukrainians
race to the shelters in the city of
mario paul under attack from russia
above ground they try and contain the
damage done by shelling to their
property and families
i don't worry about myself i worry about
children they wake up and they cry
asking what happened mom what do i say
to him the war
he doesn't get it at all he asked what
should i do
this is thought to be hostile airport
just outside of kiev taken by russian
special forces then reportedly retaken
by ukrainians
ukraine's president addressed his nation
last night accusing russia of wanting to
decapitate his government
i remain in the capital my family is
also in ukraine my children are in
ukraine
my family are not traitors they are
citizens of ukraine
where exactly they are i have no right
to say
according to the information we have the
enemy has marked me as target number one
my family as target number two
they want to damage ukraine politically
by destroying the head of state
ukraine's ministry of defense claims its
forces have mounted stiff resistance to
russia's attacks but russia has captured
key sites including chernobyl
sadly i have to inform you that as of
now the chernobyl zone the so-called
chernobyl exclusion zone and all the
structures of the chernobyl nuclear
power plants are under the control of
the russian armed groups
according to the management of the
chernobyl exclusion zone and the
chernobyl nuclear power plant there have
been no casualties
the information will be updated
russia claims it's defending people here
in separatist controlled eastern parts
of ukraine there has been shelling here
with casualties
in around three minutes another shell
came here right into the factory
workshop and those people were hit who
didn't have time to hide
but russia has launched far more than a
defensive operation a massive
multi-pronged invasion across ukraine's
borders raising the prospect of europe's
biggest land war since world war ii
dominic waghorn sky news moscow